[Music]
a little over one year ago christian and
i embarked on an adventure a
movie-making adventure that we talk
about probably too often on the show and
we just got some very good news for all
of you uh the movie will be coming out
in july we just inked a deal
it'll be in the trade soon called lady
the manner anyway so everyone will be
able to see it and uh all the people who
are sick of hearing us talk about it
we'll get to finally see it but while we
were shooting that toward the end of
production
ryan phillippe who was one of the actors
in the movie he told us like pretty
matter-of-factly that there's going to
be this life-altering pandemic that was
like february of 2020 right we dismissed
it we thought i mean everyone there
pretty much thought i thought he's crazy
yeah i know how to say that i thought he
was like oh because i didn't know ryan
that well
uh and i thought well maybe i just
missed the part i really liked him but i
thought i missed the part where he's
like this like crazy conspiracy theory
guy and um obviously he was um
he was right unfortunately he was right
i know sadly so he turned out to be like
a gorgeous nostradamus
yeah nostradamus
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is uh my equally
prophetic brother do you think i said
pathetic no i thought you said prophetic
you still think it's weird well are you
saying that we're equally not prophetic
yeah yeah okay okay well it's a strange
way to be described
it's like
my brother who's also not a gymnast
i guess so
well we can be a little pro we have
degrees of prophetic uh ability you
don't bother to have degrees of
propheticism
you know now i'm thinking about
nostradamus being gorgeous like ryan
phillippe and he might have been he
might have been but you know every once
in a while you'll see like an old-timey
like
you know i'm thinking of there's a
president who i think it's chester a
arthur
i think chester a are he had the big
mutton chops
didn't he he had a big beard um
did he have mutton shops maybe he did
are you thinking of grover cleveland i
i think arthur had big mutton shots
don't look it up don't look it up well i
want to just because there's a photo of
young chester arthur who is um
uh whatever uh he's anyways what's your
point
well he's so
handsome he looks like a modern day
handsome guy you know he looks like drew
brees weirdly
um with more hair but uh anyway i'm just
imagining like hunky uh historical
figures hunky nostradamus yeah maybe he
was under nostradamus had one of those
big that was like trendy for uh prophets
at the time that there were hunky
people back then that was the go-to
prophet luke
here's the difference big white beard
here's the difference is that people now
um have
much better nutrition and knowledge
about what they put in their body and
that's true and skin care products true
so ryan phillippe obviously is naturally
extremely handsome
but he's also fortunate enough to take
care of himself really well yeah whereas
nostradamus i would guess
didn't have that ability well maybe he
he could predict that um that was
important that he would maybe he would
age
poorly still wouldn't have access to
this the skin care regimen yeah i know
but didn't they was probably like fleshy
probably ate a lot of meat yeah i get
because information might have had nice
features yeah yeah that i think that's
the case with the guy i'm thinking of
chester arthur chester arthur is that he
was yeah when he was younger it's like i
i think people just aged faster like
much faster well we were talking about
he also died younger we were talking
about um tom brady and george george
blanda was the oldest professional
football player to have played he was i
think 48 when he retired and um he
played in a game in a playoff game and
tom brady just beat his record for being
the oldest quarterback in a playoff game
uh and george blind was 42 at the time
tom brady's 43 still doing it in the
super bowl um anyway they showed a
picture back to back of george blanda at
his at the same age as tom brady and of
course tom brady
looked like resplendent and george
blanda looked like his father yeah he
did he was that much older look you saw
the difference yeah yeah it was crazy
but of course george bland also smoked
he he drank a lot of he was like
back then in the 60s 70s that's what
football a lot also even now but don't
get me started on tom right now he has a
new student for this day and age yeah he
is like freakishly young looking for his
age and he i thought you were gonna say
he has like he's like freakishly
disciplined about it yeah but that's why
he looks like that yeah but they go hand
in hand why are we talking about this
well because we're talking about uh uh
why aren't we ryan
that's right phillippi
he was in our movie he was in a he was
in a great movie wait wait you're saying
like our movie's not great
it hasn't been seen yet yes it hasn't
been uh
reviewed isn't that that's the nice
thing about before a movie comes out
like you can toggle hard perfect perfect
reviews it's great so far we can say
it's great without people rolling their
eyes right what do you mean it's great
uh but it is great i think and um
hopefully you'll agree but yeah he was
in a great i think one of the greatest
movies one of the greatest comedies of
the last 20 years of this century i i
think easily mcgruber mcgruber was a
takeoff on macgyver who um
we
we wouldn't watch growing up at the
commercials we're always on and i
remember once watching the commercial
with my mother my mother
commented on richard dean anderson was
the actor who played he commented on his
looks and she was like oh
uh he's uh you know whatever he liked
that she liked him and i i remember
thinking because i was so young it was
before i understood that
mothers could be attracted to people
other than
your father other fathers you know so i
at the time i just remember thinking oh
well she thinks she likes him she finds
him attractive the same way i do because
he's like cool and he like makes bombs
out of twine maybe she did yeah
richard dean anderson also dylan mckay's
father in 90210 is that true yes whoa
that's pretty cool i was a big 90210
that's right forget
what do you call yourselves the 902 one
owers 90210 heads yeah he just made that
up um but anyway anyway yeah so mcgruber
was based on macgyver but it was based
on an snl sketch
called mcgruber and um the movie
underperformed at the box office but as
it has since gone on to become
a cult classic and the star and
writer
of that movie is our guest today
will
forte
he is uh
just i think one of the i mean i i now i
can't say that anymore because i
i catch myself saying he's one of the
funniest people i've ever met but
he is he is i mean how can you not say
that i mean i i think i've just been
really lucky too
you've also talked in real life and on
the show
with now
multiple
members of saturday night live which is
a show
has
some of the funniest people yeah in the
country yeah okay so it's of course
you're gonna you're gonna talk you're
talking about like elite level
people i know it's like saying like yeah
here's another member of the men's
u.s olympic swimming team who's he's
also a really good swimmer exactly it's
like duh okay i'm gonna stop being
self-conscious about it um or try to and
yeah will is uh he's you'll see you're
gonna hear he's the best and
if you haven't seen mcgruber which
probably most of you have uh god is it
worth it you should watch it but he's
also um very funny in last men on earth
which was a tv show on
fox for
four years one of those rare really
funny and smart network comedies really
smart and he's good he's a great actor
too he was the star of alexander payne's
nebraska he's a good dramatic actor yeah
he can kind of do it all i think and
we'll talk about this afterwards but i
think any time uh you see an actor
committing the way he does even in those
saturn live sketches he does
he commits in a way that
it's then unsurprising when he commits
to a traumatic performance i think but
we'll get into that
um let's talk to will about
oh god i'm so looking forward to this
because um i've always wanted to pick
his brain about well about a lot of
things but but really i mean mcgruber is
this really special movie does so we get
into that and many more things
with the great the hilarious the
absurdly funny will forte
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
wait why am i not showing up on the
screen here
it's so nice it's nice to see your voice
um but it's just a black uh it doesn't
even oh god i'm such a
freaking piece of tape
sorry i heard you say once that you um
are so intimidated by certain people
one of the reasons i i love being around
you i feel connected to you is um
we have a similar thing which is that
people that we admire people that we
respect um it's very still
very difficult for us to be
natural and normal around them i think
you said it about steve martin martin
short there was a moment where a
director friend of mine was like you got
to come it was after a play and martin
short was there and
it was it was a good group it was like a
group i was comfortable around he was
like just come
say hi and i i couldn't do it i didn't
want i don't know why and i'm the nicest
person in the world i know he's i know
he's so easy to talk to and i just get
so nervous i i actually sat next to him
on a plane once and i was he was walking
down the aisles and i was kind of
dreading like oh my god what if i'm
sitting next to him and then it was the
seat oh my god
nightmare because i was like i don't
know what to say i don't know and it was
the most delightful plane ride i've ever
had he
uh
told me the most amazing stories uh
it seems like that kind of effortlessly
incredibly funny the whole time and and
i learned a lot about him personally
just just an amazing person and
i've kept in touch with him a little bit
but but i just i just feel like in such
awe of him
that i don't know your comedy to me is
so
unique and great and i'm i i am in awe
of what you do so i'm i'm so curious
what what did form that i've never
gotten to ask you that we've known each
other for years but i mean i think it's
basically
every little thing you watch and you
like but the the stuff that really
that i
loved so much obviously saturday night
live growing up and just seeing
you know basically i i was born in 1970
so i was old enough to
kind of be aware of that first cast uh
as i got a little bit older at the
letterman show the in the
early to mid 80s and then
i just wouldn't miss that ever and he
was
that was a big one that was the guy
martin yeah
and uh yeah
chubby chase all his movies fletch
was huge caddyshack obviously
i'm gonna make you tell a story i'm sure
you've i'm so sorry to do this but will
you just tell the story about the
character that you auditioned for on
centering live the gold character oh
yes
there was
a character that i had done at the
groundlings a bunch of times yeah is one
of my favorite sketches i ever got a
chance to do
you know the
usually they're they're people who are
either dressed all in silver or dressed
all in gold and then they're frozen yeah
they're frozen
um standing on just standing in the in
the street and they have a little box
and if you throw money into the box
they'll do some robotic movement
a little bit just enough to earn that
buck and and then they'll
freeze again
um so i played one of those guys
basically the premise of the thing was
that i did that for somebody you know
i'm i'm one of those guys somebody
throws in some some money i do some
robotic movement and then people get
kind of bored of me
and look at somebody else on the street
and
then a person comes up a
a street uh robber
and looks around nobody's paying
attention so he takes all the money out
of my jar but since he doesn't put money
into the jar i don't do the movement and
i'm stuck there frozen
oh because the sign says dollars make me
move so right um so then he takes off
and i'm just frozen there finally
somebody else comes up
puts in
a buck
and
i take off robotically to try to find
this guy but he's already long gone so i
sadly get back up on the the pedestal
and and just sit there with a really sad
look on my face and then uh
this kid comes up with their dad and
says yeah why is the cold man look so
sad and he says well i don't know if you
if you uh put in a dollar maybe he'll
tell you and if you put in two dollars
maybe he'll tell you in song
and then i do this
this song
about how hard it is to be a gold man
um
which then
this was for this was your snl audition
i decided to do this for the snl
audition i guess i should just sing it
because it seems like a bunga yeah i
should just sing it yeah you have to
please please favorite us with um so
this was
yeah this was the very end of my snl
audition
and then i launched into this song and
this is how it was
just because i'm a man made of gold
doesn't mean i'm made out of money
but the calling i found is to give
people pleasure
their incredibly precise robotic
movement
that's why i come out to the streets
to help me make ends meet
and i work real hard to fill up that jar
and then a bad apple ruins the barrel
heart of gold
24 carat
but through all the pain
a grin and i buried heart of gold
but i'm living a golden dream
and any way you slice it we're all on
the same team and then everyone kind of
comes out it becomes this real
feel-good part of the song you know
everyone who has been watching comes out
kind of like joining a heart of gold 24
karat but through all the pain i grin
and i bear it and then my root off goes
he grants
a heart of gold
and then it gets a little cd but it
don't make me no saint cause i got a
little secret i saw [ __ ] for my face
pain
cocktail faceman facebook facebook just
keep going on there of course there's a
musical backing
and
i just
keep going and and singing the words
[ __ ] face paint how long did you how
long did you go for it just until the
song ended it's not much longer than
that but like it's just
you know the last
i don't know minute and a half of the
song is just the words [ __ ] and baby
um
and so um
i get done i get done with this audition
and then
people don't really laugh or people
laugh or clap or anything i i don't know
there might have been one or two people
but they're only like i don't know there
are six people in there
in the whole oh yeah because it's lauren
and i think marcie line is there
probably tina fey i believe was there
um and there are people this is being
piped
out to i think burbank where people are
watching from there
you get done and you don't really know
what what you've just done like did they
like it did they not like it yeah
collected my stuff right that was it and
i started walking out in there and i saw
lauren
uh he shook my hand
and i i just said thank you
sorry about all the [ __ ] and
yes oh no i didn't even say
i can't i think i just said sorry about
all the [ __ ] and then just left
and that was and then next thing i knew
it though i got the job but it was oh my
god it was did you ever there's a more
concise way to tell that story so i
apologize i had heard that recently and
it made me laugh so hard i and also i
think is really an important story in
terms of who you are comedically at
least to me because you're somebody who
we've had other people on the show um
like taran was on the show fred from snl
and
everyone says about you that you were
their favorite you were the ones i mean
you were their favorite you were the one
who um
they admired the most and and you are
that to me because you took these crazy
like absurdist chances and
oh no will and and that's in fact there
are a lot of i asked people their
favorite sketch that didn't make it and
you are always the star
i had a lot of sketches that didn't make
it that's for sure yeah yeah like dress
rehearsal star like the
the sketch that would be just a little
too weird and my favorite sketches were
like calhoun and like the ones that you
did
you know the falcon the ones that were
like the second to last or the last
sketch those to me are me oh thank you
tim calhoun that was another one i got
to do at the you know that came from the
groundlings so
oh that's right
in my audition too oh just one more
thing about that uh the gold man
he actually tried to put it up
um
for the show that's right right that's
right they made you cut the [ __ ] out
yeah you couldn't say cox so but but but
they uh i put it up and and we had
um
substituted different euphemisms
and it was
i learned a big lesson because it was
just wasn't the same that was one of my
favorite things i ever got to do with
the groundlings and then thank god they
didn't pick it and i was like one day
maybe you'll be able to say [ __ ] on
on nbc
it's just yeah one day you will be able
to but but it's a that's a dream
yeah and i know you got to do some of
those sketches on seth's show um
on seth meyer's show where it was like
the sketches that didn't make it then
you get to perform them but it's like
well what is that you've already set
them up in a way that um you don't know
exactly know why people are appreciating
them yeah it's that's such a fun thing
to do because there's no way to lose
when you do his second chance theater
because
you talk about it for so long in the
panel interview
and so you get to talk about the sketch
so much that people
are
they're either gonna yeah they're
invested and they're either gonna
they're either gonna think it's funny or
they're gonna think it's horrendous and
they're gonna be laughing because i
can't believe you ever cared about this
sketch so much
yeah so so it's misleading it's like oh
my god it's so funny you say that
because the the uh i have to put this up
that somebody
had i so i went and it was while i was
doing uh last man on earth so i had a
beard and a beard was never what the
character was going to be
but somebody actually watched the
segment and then just disappeared
out of nowhere
will's holding up a painting like a
really great painting he's bald he's got
a beer and he's got um he sent it like
eyeliner
oh my god like
some who sent you these they're both
it's a wonderful art student this was
several years ago
and i kept their address beautiful work
it's weird it's um a painting of you
with like heavy eye shadow on yeah blue
eyeshadow and a big
it's just a big it looks exactly like
the character as it was on uh seth
meyer's show so it it
this person was
just sent this over i have no idea how
they found my address i guess i guess
that's
right now
i just moved by the way so so uh good
luck finding the next one guys and i
saved their letter and i've i've now i'm
sure they've moved and i'll never be
able to uh reach out to them but if you
were that person
please uh reach out because i i want to
say thank you because i've always
intended to get back to them but they
didn't they didn't have a phone number
so it meant that i had to to send them a
letter and i'm just such a dumbass with
correspondence
i uh go find it yes
oh wow hi
it's amazing you found it
will has found i got it
yes
all right i'm such a dumb ass i'm seeing
right now that they even left their
email so so i could have emailed too
it wasn't just an address
all right well okay well they i'm sure i
can get in uh
in touch with this person okay they said
yeah um
dear second chance theater uh
wf
pals i think in clothes you'll find two
paintings oil board of gentleman
franklin from second chance theater the
painting slipped my mind until spring
cleaning and i deemed the portraits too
dangerous to keep around the house
too much sexuality for one gal to have
hanging on the walls you have to see
these paintings because it's yeah
that is a very nice
sarcastic
maybe we should explain the sketch too
it was genjamin franklin was yeah it was
two people who had a friend who uh who
had a single friend and they were trying
to set them up with this single friend
and the single friend ended up being
uh genjiman franklin was was had all
these nice attributes am i explaining
this correctly yeah so so the people
were trying to
set me up but yeah we had we shared some
common interests and it was
all about like you know oh you're gonna
you're gonna love this woman yeah she's
a big fan of history and and this and
you know kind of
you know colonial
don't know i don't remember all this
stuff but it was you know
and
almanacs yeah
like
this person this woman who is the
spitting image of
benjamin franklin whose name is genjamin
franklin
and things get very flirtatious and
sexual and somehow
this person is
into it even though i look like
i not only i'm a woman who looks like
benjamin franklin but also have a beard
which he didn't have right he did not
have a beard no yeah but he had you know
he's he's got male pattern baldness
up on top
well you had the beard because you had
the beard because you when you did it on
seth's you were you had the beard for
last night on earth yeah yeah yeah okay
so no sorry was it the half beard
it was no it was full beard oh okay all
right so
so
so someone a fan made
i'm guessing a fan
uh made a painting oh my god do you know
what i'm just seeing right now
she said i think i have a slightly
larger one kicking around somewhere too
what how did i
and i this is just
like how do i not just immediately say
this is the coolest thing i've ever seen
thank you
oh my god search for the bigger one
well can i answer that for you so you
don't you don't sound like a dick yeah
let me preface by saying chances are
this person is like
totally sweet and insane
but but
there is
a chance that um
that it's not the case that there's
maybe
she
it might be become problematic where you
two engage in a
in a correspondence you know what that's
a good point now you've you've made me
feel much better even though that had
nothing to do with me
corresponding with her
yeah just being
lazy i just i don't know you you know
you
yeah i have piles of stuff to do and
then yeah i'll i'm
all like if i'm if i have a project i'm
doing
you get to the end of it you don't want
to like
take the time to
write back a nice letter you're like oh
i want to do that but not today i'm kind
of tired i've just been working i want
to sit down and play my tiny wings or or
do a crossword
or obsessively watch
msnbc or something like that so
something important i know and then it
just builds up a little bit at a time
and then you're like oh now i feel like
doing it but where do i start so
i just it's just like i have these i
will this is
2000
june 4th 2017. and i have oh look at
this wait this is what a horrible person
i am
397 unread texts oh my god he's showing
me his phone 309 okay now i feel 4 502
unread emails
holy [ __ ]
do you
phone messages i haven't listened to a
horrible
i'm so curious about them aren't you
aren't you those tech 347 texts um from
people you know i'm presuming mostly
yeah well i mean with that one thing
that was a big one that really
uh stopped things up was i was at a
friend's wedding
in
france a buddy of mine one of my closest
friends got married in france and it was
the the actual ceremony was
at the exact moment that the emmys
announced the nominations and this was
the first year of last man on earth and
i got nominated for
uh for acting and writing which was
amazing and and yeah so i got just a ton
of emails from
from friends and co-workers
but i was watching
somebody get married sure yeah
and it addressed that it's at the end of
the day and then we go to this reception
and we're drinking so all of a sudden
the next day
um we were also still trying to prepare
for
last man on earth we were and i just you
know had this backlog started there and
then and then you know
you have a birthday and a bunch of
people dad and then i just when it gets
to a certain point i just go oh i'm
giving up then you find oh i haven't
responded in however many days then it
becomes rude then it demands you can't
just say oh haha or
you have to explain your absence
i i don't blame you i think it's a good
problem to have i mean you're
lucky that these things have been you've
just been you've been busy
well i mean it's not it's not always
that sometimes it's
you know i went through a period for a
couple
years of
like last minute on earth that period
was a real mixed bag i mean obviously i
loved the show and was proud of the show
and thrilled to work with the people i
worked with it was just a big wonderful
family of people but it was also
the craziest amount of work and i i bet
like one the first year i i think i
maybe
went and did
nine social things like for instance new
years of that first year
i was writing until
11 55 and i went next door and
and watched the ball drop with my
neighbors and then went back home at
12 10 and started writing again it was
that level of
work and it's not a bad it's not a good
excuse it's like
it's just about setting priorities and i
i didn't yeah you know i prioritized the
show and and yeah let a lot of
friendships slide for a while and i feel
really guilty and i
you know a lot of well people i have a
lot of apologies to make
well we can do it right now uh where do
you want to begin
with me go to my first
yeah
go to the first text back let's go down
the text and just see i'm gonna go down
for a while
i'm going to go down
a significant amount and then i'm just
going to pick one that i did
okay i don't even know who that person
is so i feel bad about that one
i want to hear that one okay frederick
my friend frederick frederick frederick
frederick bond
i'm sorry and here's your apology he
said i'm
back in l.a
um ready to kick some ass on the tennis
court
uh let me know if you're a game for a
game or if you just want to sit in
silence on the court
and pretend to read your book and
frederick's awesome and that's funny
this funny text this was
like a 2018 a year and a half ago
and i freaking
[ __ ] that dude over and i didn't say
anything so frederick i'm sorry
well maybe he's still on the court uh
scott grimes this wonderful man that i
met several years ago he and his really
good actor
any chance he'll be in san diego for
comic-con were you july 18 2018. i might
have even been there no i don't think i
was that but but i mean you're down
there and it's you're you're you are on
a schedule
and that was back in the you know back
in those days you're i remember we would
they'd they got us driven down there and
i
worked on the computer with we brought a
couple writers and we were working
in the background
too i mean in writing and it's a single
camera show so you're scott i'm talking
to scott right now scott it's he knows
he's an actor it's round the clock
shooting
it's it's like doing
imagine you're doing the critters tv
show and you're writing on it yeah and
and editing also you know it's i mean we
have editors and writers but but you
know i i
was kind of
i was very hands-on and a little
freaky so let's see i'll go back a
little further okay
and by the way that's 400 unread ones
there are so many that i read and didn't
respond to you i mean
what a dick
wait okay you found one
pat driscoll oh my god patrick this is
2016.
hey i'm in town through next friday
sure you're busy but if you have some
time love to grab a drink well he was
right of course no worries if you can't
but figured i'd reach out
oh i love you
guys this guy is one of the nicest guys
you'll ever meet i mean all these people
all three of these people are people who
are basically
uh not in my life anymore because i i
haven't reached out in a while so i'm
i'm gonna change that because they're
all fantastic people how do you do that
how do you uh yes do you have an
assistant i mean like you can't have an
assistant respond to those
can you take a day do you just i did
have this fantasy that i was just gonna
start
going down that list and just going and
and
and calling to people and just you know
yeah
i'm sorry
you know yeah it's it's
and
and and then i go why not just
it's super easy to just say i'm gonna
i'm gonna do five a week or uh-huh you
know five a week that's easy or one a
day how about one a day and then
everyone understands i would understand
if somebody called me and said i'm so
sorry i was been super busy if you know
if you call up and say hey you're you're
a person i love i want you
i want you in my life but you know i i
think i i would understand that if
somebody called up and i'd say yeah you
know what i've been doing well that you
might like actually it might come in
handy for this is the voice text is that
is the voice memo text you can just hold
the thing down yeah do you ever do that
yeah you know what you know what i do
i've started really
taking a road trip and just calling
people i've needed to catch up with yes
that's the that's that's
great i try to be a nice person but i'm
like this mixture of
a really
nice person and a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it's so well like that's
not true i think i know what it comes
from a little bit i used to i used to be
kind of a pushover a little earlier i
would just do a lot of things for
other people
and i would get com complaints from the
people who i was really close with that
like
if i wanted something done
i'd need to know you less like you
prioritize people you don't know over
the people you do
and i realize you're freaking
dead right so i tried to
start doing the other way around and
then i then what i ended up doing was
not prioritizing those people but just
playing video games and just
yeah so it's i don't know
i don't know i i'm i always feel like
there's a good person in here that
that some people get to see some people
don't and like this podcast is a good
reminder that oh that's right i want to
be a nice person
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
from my perspective you are one of the
nicest but i also understand the flip
side which is
the amount of time that you've you've
had to expend
doing things professionally you know
don't shortchange that either i mean
like you've been a really
busy human being i think with me it's
more just my
my brain
i've never been like a diagnosed ocd
person but i definitely
have
some level of ocd and i think it comes
in you know sometimes i get a little
more
swept up in minutia and just like
thinking about things and and and it i
you know it's harder for me to break out
of
patterns and so it's it's i don't know i
don't want to how does that manifest
well like what what's that i hate using
that as that some excuse because there
are people no no super debilitating so i
don't i don't
throw that around there is definitely
uh you know i have to bring my fiance
around to say hey
you know like we
we left uh
from our our place down south a couple
days ago and when i'm going out i'm like
okay i'm gonna go check that all the
showers are off and stuff come watch
with me and she's watching as i'm doing
my patterns and i'm like these are all
off right she's like
yes they're off let's go and then then i
have to go to the other bathroom it's
like is it all faucet related no is it
some stoves
oh no kidding and stoves are crazy
because
for 20 years i don't think i i maybe
used the stove twice i would just go out
all the time but i would still
religiously
check those [ __ ] stoves how does your
fiance process that what did she say
about it is she like
well does she roll her eyes or she like
this is this isn't normal this is part
of who i am and she yeah she shakes her
head and she's she's i think kind of
fascinated by it a little fascinated a
little annoyed and just like i gotta
deal with this because this is how you
are and
it's part of you and she loves you yeah
and my you know my mom
various people in in my life have have
told me i should go see somebody about
it and i i
feel like you know what i i can go out
of the house i can there are people who
have it in
incredibly debilitating ways and and i'm
lucky to not be
somebody like that but it's it does
affect like it affects relationships and
you know it comes out in in other ways
that are not just destruction related
fears completing tasks is a big thing
so if you get me around a jigsaw puzzle
you know
just say goodbye to
whatever evening you thought you were
gonna have me um well
which is fascinating to me will because
you strike me as somebody who is and
this is what i love
about the show i love
getting to learn things like this from
people i admire because what one of the
things i admire so much about you is
your fearlessness you have this sense to
me
what you do on stage you were talking
about um
doing just the the gold man on the
audition that must take such balls it
must take such confidence
and it's an interesting juxtaposition
that you were able to do that and some
of the characters you played on snl
tim calhoun i'm thinking of just [ __ ]
weird and like for network tv
and and there's not as if you don't seem
to have any fear you commit to those
things
that's very nice of you to say first of
all thank you i mean first of all it is
scary to do a lot of times like some of
that stuff especially the first time you
do it you know you don't know how the
audience is gonna react and it's like
jumping out of an airplane i guess it's
it's right yeah scary i don't know i
guess it's because i'm so
needing to control control stuff i think
it's like here's something i can't
control here it is um yeah
oh my god interesting i have no idea i
mean it's oh that's i mean i like i
don't know how else to explain because
to me that that is that i mean it's that
level of
fearlessness that is required is like
jumping out of an airplane uh but
sometimes that parachute doesn't open
well that's the thing what do you so
what does that feel like cause i don't
i've had versions of that people
you know you just feel like what am i
doing in this business and i remember
god before i got my first writing job
i i almost just left the business i was
just like
had had one just really bad night
at on stage where i was
just thought oh people hate me and i
felt it's hard to have a bad night even
even now after you know you you think
you're immune to it and it's you know
it's
it hurts to be
doing something that
is what you love doing and have people
not like it and i've i've experienced a
lot of that oh my god i've done a lot of
stuff that people have not liked so
uh so well what's up but but then what
is it like because when you commit to
something like that and you're as funny
as you are
is there a part of you when they don't
like it do you ever think so i'm
thinking specifically now about mcgruber
which is i think the funniest studio
movie that was made in the last 10 years
but at the time when it comes out
doesn't do well do you think
is it a huge letdown or do you think god
i know this is funny like i
they're
almost like they're wrong
that was a good lesson one because
yeah it's it's hard not to at first
just feel like
oh my god
what a failure
you take a couple weeks and you're like
you know what we've got to make the
movie that we wanted to make
we just thought we wouldn't have changed
a thing so so there was a little part of
us that was like you know what
[ __ ] you i'm proud of this movie like i
don't know yeah it's not it's
doesn't this one's not on us this one's
on you and certainly you know yeah it's
it's not a movie that's for everybody uh
but but we never thought that we we we
wanted to make a movie that that we
would have wanted to see
and yeah and well that's only
me yorma and john we wanted to make that
movie the movie the three of us would
see so the fact that more than three
people saw it was a win for us
i'm glad we didn't take any kind of
notes to try to make it more
commercial because then
so much of it's out of your control
probably would have bombed anyway well
when you're and then you're like what
whatever but i was you know that's why
we could go okay i'm you know this this
week i stand by this this was
this was what i thought would be funny
and i'm not you know
it's kind of still i think it sucks and
it's like well i
disagree respectfully i
totally disagree but but um it's kind of
what you were saying about this the
sketch where the um
the gold man sucking [ __ ] the [ __ ] thing
was like
you know if you you if you don't do that
the right way if you don't like really
commit to that the if you don't use the
word [ __ ]
it just so it loses something and
there's something really special that
whatever made it funny or special or
um and i'm thinking about macgruber had
mcgruber been sanitized and
wouldn't be as special as it is um
you're you're lucky if you get one
chance to write something and
and be in the thing you wrote so it's
it's yeah um you know i
am
many levels of appreciative to so many
different people
um for
somehow taking a chance
even
even you know after so many bombs in a
row it's like hey why don't we give
another chance this guy who's
nothing but but uh
i'm so glad they did it's
i watch it all the time and i'm i i got
to work with ryan with philippe a couple
months ago and
he
got it funny he's like shockingly funny
i had no idea he is one of the most
important
ingredients in that movie because yeah
without him
he grounds he's playing the straight man
amazing way him in yeah
oh yeah
really committing i mean like he allows
you to do these ridiculous things um
because he's really committed to it what
what made you think about ryan what made
you think about what made you think to
cast it that way to to go after powers
booth and ryan phillippi the tough
decision going in just before even
thinking about any individuals is like
you have
all of you know this is coming from the
saranac
saturday night live family so you have
access to all these
amazing people like oh do you do you get
like a
sedacus or hater or sandburg or fred or
you know um
just all these awesome people and then
we thought you know it's it's i think it
would be
valuable to the movie to to try to fill
out the rest of the world like like
already we have
um
me and wig and maya
if we're trying to do these
somewhat
legitimate action movies let's fill out
the rest of the cast with
with
legit
actors that that aren't so comedy so so
you know you can really
present that world in that way so like
once we realized that which was a hard
decision to make because you're
you do a lot of guesswork in your head
like well had somebody do this so but
they could do this and i don't know and
then then
then ryan is is
out there and you're like oh my god he's
is just like a
real a real actor
like yeah
it just made all the sense in the world
and and same with powers it's like there
was
such a gravitas to
totally his presence and and i mean that
voice alone that power is good mcgruber
yeah it's just
we're taking you off this one mcgrubbie
yeah it's so he's got immediate
authority and yeah but you're also
committing in a way that matches what
those guys are doing it's just
it's just like a thing of yours
to have
the
gravitas commitment and like the
straight man commitment that that right
like they're committing in an equal way
at that same level that that allows us
to be such nuts and so it's it's
it's really they're they're the heroes
of the movie as far as i'm concerned
the last thing about mcgruber i just
want to ask about the the sex scene
where you how because because there's a
wide i've studied that i've seen it so
many times and i there's a on the wider
shot i you can see kristin kind of
turning her head
and laughing
was she am i imagining that or was she
laughing a lot and are there outtakes of
that
i mean she she is
such an amazing actress i mean obviously
she's like the you know baseball the
five tool player she's she can just yeah
there's nothing she can't do and this
was just a rare this it was her birthday
um
birthday uh new mexico in
where
happy
yeah super hot day jesus albuquerque
right upstairs floor albuquerque yep
the second
story of this house so already it's hot
the heat's rising up there big movie
lights
uh lighting everything and so i and i am
i'm a sweater i tend to sweat when i
not if i'm just sitting like like if i'm
sitting around in the heat i can usually
hang in there but if i
like if i were to
you know just start snapping
and it's hot enough then i'd just
eventually start
pouring your fingers slip wet yeah yeah
it will take me like 60 seconds and i'm
sweating everywhere and i'm also a hairy
man so
so this
in this close-up that you're talking
about like she was just
dodging all kinds of incoming
huge i mean you can see
you can see water droplets that are like
somebody's blowing bubbles
on
down on her it's they're
they're so so big and and just she'd get
just be
matted down with
sweat and hair when we were done with
the take and it's just like i i
felt so bad that that was how she had to
spend her birthday and then they
everyone else felt so bad too that the
production
uh got her a hotel room in santa fe and
center up there and i thought yeah
massage
package to try to
make it go away
so it was mo it was more the sweat it
was more like the droplets of sweat and
not the um the heaving orgasm that you
you're having it wasn't
she was she wasn't the oh i mean i don't
i don't i i
i i don't know what it was i just i
think we caught her in a rare moment
where she holy [ __ ]
like
how did i wind up here what the [ __ ] was
going on
yeah
so you guys is the best of the best
she's the best i know
in fact i remember talking to her right
before she did that and um
i i said i remember having this
conversation i was like
wait they're doing a sketch because i
like the sketch i said but i remember
thinking they're doing a movie from that
sketch i didn't know how they were going
to expand it and she said
it's one of the funniest scripts i've
ever read it's pretty i remember going
on about the script
and i have been so confused by that
project and
you know it's something i've seen i
don't know how many times now
oh god is i'm so glad you're doing the
series is it is it are you done with the
first season no we're so we wrote the
whole thing
all eight episodes and then we
did a rewrite pass and i think we have
to go and do another one
which is more of like a
budget pass to try to get the budget you
know to make it a little more producible
which is something we did with the movie
and a lot of my
favorite scenes from the movie are
scenes that came because they were
because we had to cut down the budget
like the oh no we're all wet the guy
that we rip his throat out and then he's
uh you're all oh the cup the cup
dropping
that was a yeah budget cut scene and now
it's like oh no kidding the scene that
it replaced was
so blah and so it's you know funny so
so i i think this will end up making the
scripts even better but it's it's
i i think anybody who liked the movie
is
i i would i would think will like this
it's same girl
just
some some really fun
stuff we're excited to do but yeah we'd
wow we i can't wait are excited to in
and
you know excited to have
um
the the
basically the the
core group yep oh wow that's great i
mean that's great well i like that now
so
okay that's exciting um i'm taking way
too much advantage of your time i just
have like a lightning round okay uh if
you have a little bit more time
yeah yeah
i said um yeah which was a heck of an
[ __ ] yeah at the same time
yeah [ __ ] yeah
huck yas
what is your most commonly used emoji
uh definitely the uh kiss kissing the
heart i do that a lot um
i don't i think it yeah in any kind of
context
to a friend yeah yeah you should just
right you should just rifle off a couple
of those to all the missing all the
unanswered tags
i feel like they deserve better than
that especially after yeah four years if
you could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play basketball i suck
at it i can't play but i i love watching
basketball and i feel like me too i love
football and i i played football in high
school
but i just that's right i feel like
i'd be scared i'd be
too much fear of like cte stuff um
baseball i don't react fast enough to be
able to hit a baseball i don't think and
basketball just seems like less of a
chance of injury and it's just
it's really a skill that i don't have at
all
um so it's so i'm
just incredibly impressed i mean i'm
impressed by all
professional athletes it's it's so
incredible were you have
49ers i was a raiders fan
i was a raiders wow
and it's really i'm in a weird place
with them right now because they left
him with las vegas and left uh yeah my
hometown of oakland and uh
that's where i was born and
i am still
having mixed feelings about them i
thought that it was a
poor form to leave
oakland but there's a little part of me
that
hasn't been willing to give my whole
heart to them this year um and who's the
team oh they go and the warriors then um
you you've gotten some wow
somehow i'm a clippers fan i i was
because i told you i was i
i was uh i
don't know how to play basketball i'm
shitty so i didn't become a fan of
basketball until i went to ucla for
college so by then i had and the other
thing was the golden state warriors if
they were the oakland warriors it sucked
that they just automatically would have
been my team because it was from oakland
but even as a kid i didn't understand
that
they were from
oakland
because it didn't
it was just weird to oh golden state
yeah
what's that i know golden state is
california but it's like i don't want to
share a team with
the whole with sacramento and yeah san
diego i wanted it to be oakland and i
just was too young to get it and so so
uh you know where i became a basketball
fan and then was down there and the
easiest way to see
basketball cheaply was to
go to clippers games
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life well what would it
be the first thing that came to my mind
was cheez-its but i'm sure that i liked
it uh it's specifically like a candy or
chip or something
candy chip any sort of snack you're
stoned you wanna you just wanna
munch on munch on something probably a
breakfast burrito then
oh okay yeah
yeah
i did say munch yeah that could be a
snack um
ice cream what is your favorite cookies
for the ice cream brownie sundae
uh mud pie cookies dipped in ice cream
potato chips just any form of potato
chips i'm just just i'm you just got me
going now potato chips with uh onion dip
sounds pretty good to me right now
basically everything sounds good right
now
right that's right
uh what is your favorite what's your
favorite movie sequel of all time your
favorite sequel my favorite sequel i
mean it's probably gonna be the
godfather
uh
yeah
godfather two right three
yeah part three
right like everybody um or i mean aliens
is
is pretty oh i mean
terminator terminator
yes which i just saw the first forget
about how great
the original terminator is too
i just saw it again for the first time
the first time in a long time i mean
oh then that just made me think of uh oh
[ __ ] what was i
um
rambo first blood too first blood two
but i mean the first blood
i love for wait it goes rambo no it goes
first blood
then rambo first blood two
yeah and then called rambo first blood
two it's rambo is first blood too right
rambo
well whatever first blood test
i should know this the one i knew the
best was rambo three
when he goes to afghanistan and fights
the the russians with the they're all
yeah
for some reason that's the one that um
i know so much better than the other two
uh what's the what what do most people
answer on that one well you know what
the last we just started doing this new
question it used to be what's your
favorite movie and that became really
difficult because you know i would get a
lot of [ __ ] for that i remember alec
baldwin really shaming me
are you [ __ ] kidding what's my what's
my favorite movie one movie i'm supposed
to pick one movie
um there was a lot of that like how do i
get mine would be mine
maybe would be jaws
jaws the jerk the jerk is up there
doctor strange love
but probably jaws
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
we've been karaoking before you're so gr
you're so fun to karaoke with what
what's your what is your go-to and i've
heard we've done a lot of singing
together because we did karaoke together
and then we did uh for sure dylan fast a
couple of times right yes
god i missed him uh definitely one i
remember once we sang hurricane
hurricane for sure
um oh and we feel like we did other
things too
yeah i think you're right i think uh
that's fun
i just watched it oh my god it was so
fun i haven't seen any of those guys in
a long time yeah i haven't either um i
don't know if they still do that i know
they were getting sponsored at one point
by
some
jameson some oh that's right yeah
yeah you said you just watched what
oh uh uh
like a
behind the
some kind of documentary on the
traveling wilburys
i've
i love i've gotten i mean i've i've
always been a huge beatles fan but
somehow
i
i mean i'd love all beetles but but
george harrison just i somehow
caught on to him
too late even though i knew
all things must pass
pretty well
but but then there was this uh what's it
called early takes uh if you do you have
that album yeah um all uh
it's early takes
early takes is an album which is
basically
i could be getting this wrong but i'm
pretty sure that like when he wanted to
make this record he wanted to see if
phil spector would make it or
or he had signed up phil spectre already
and was sending him
just his own kind of stripped down
version of some of the songs and and
this is
like a lot of songs that were on on that
ended up being on all things must pass
but i don't want some other songs yeah
yeah mine is just like
a demo of super
yum it's i could have you at any time oh
wow i mean it's it's it's
so great and it just i gotta check this
out it really jumped me into
just really
uh and then the the
george harrison documentary came out and
then i just was
i just feel like just really
yeah i i
and i was kind of kicking myself for not
um
not knowing
more about him earlier
yeah um
kind of like
yeah so
but anyway so so traveling wilburys
that was just just to see
i mean i remember thinking oh this is
cool but like looking back now as i get
a little bit older and i look
just watching that there was something
really special about watching
those dudes those guys come together
yeah and i realized [ __ ] roy orbison
was only like 52 when he died and i'm
that's just he always looked like an old
guy he always had that wilfred rimley
thing where he like yeah he looked like
he was an old
an old crusty
rocker but yeah yeah i guess he was like
not
much 52 i think it was 52 could have
been 53. that's crazy yeah so george was
in his late 50s yeah
wow
yeah
um
wow well so what would be your go-to
karaoke song well
my go-to karaoke song
you sign up for one it's at it's at an
event where like tons of people are
signing up and you can only do one
okay if i am
singing
alone
yeah either going to be
uh
war pigs
with black sabbath or fairies wear boots
berries wear boots black sabbath
or
mama tried merle haggard
or
uh folsom prison blues johnny cash yeah
or just once james ingram just once
or or
but then most of the times that i do
karaoke i'm with uh sedacus
and then it'll be either
um
falling slowly that's why we did it on
last man on earth so many times because
that's just what we would sing anyway
falling slowly or i can't fight this
feeling our airspeed wagon oh i've heard
you guys do that yeah it's always in
forever as another one
uh uh oh my god our
falling slowly when we had done it so
many times that the new falling slowly
for us is uh
in the shallows or shallow lava oh in
the shadow wait is it called in the
shallows or is it just called shallows i
think shallows yeah
um
oh my god yeah that's the new one
my favorite thing to do in that is
shallow lady gaga part when
when when when it starts to turn when it
when they start to wrap up
you'll take the like power ballady part
as i recall and like
really commit to like full voiced power
singing oh yeah we love we yeah we love
it yeah and we do we do a lot of
um the the snl characters uh john bovee
the people who did the opposite band of
bon jovi would do a lot of those
uh bon jovi songs
and and and and bovey the lyrics so just
do the opposite lyrics that we used to
do
so that's kind of fun to and sometimes
we'll do that with other songs too where
we'll just try to kind of on the spot
reverse the lyrics i'm trying to think
of one of the bon jovi song now uh or uh
uh
bon jovi
or john bovee so john bovee would be
like
so bon jovi obviously is the regular
song and then john bovee
are
john yeah our bon jovi opposite band
john bovee would be like you know
um
cause i'm an indian indian
on a cotton horse i do not ride and i'm
unwanted
unwanted alive and dead oh wait the one
i've been hearing a lot is uh
uh
oh wait oh we're all the way there oh
dying on a curse take my foot we will
not make it i do not swear
oh
dying on a curse tying on a curse so
yeah
we have some that we've done a bunch
that we remember but but then there's
somebody just try to
take my foot
speaking of bon jovi who was your first
celebrity crush that you remember
cheryl ladd
remember
yeah fawcett
yep oh you sean
cassidy too i remember having a you had
a thing for that hair i had a full
length sean cassidy poster and i got the
most pissed i think i ever got anybody
was somebody ripped my poster in half
and i was
livid so so but i think i think
yeah
cheryl cheryl lad probably is
fair fawcett and
if you had a do you i don't know if you
have tattoos but if you had to get one
or if you had to get another one
what would it be
and i would wear my dogs
i would get my dogs
inside my butthole
uh it's just my own thing nobody gets to
see it but i know it's there except your
doctor maybe and you probably don't get
to see it um
yeah i'd let my doctor see it yeah and
what uh
were they what what type of dogs were
they massive dogs
uh they're pretty they're they are big
dogs they're uh i mean not huge they're
uh one is an australian shepherd
uh
yeah my butt
my butt
we were watching something we thought
the dog was named mud butt but it was
mud bud
but we had already decided oh my god mud
butt what if we ever get another dog
and then our other dog uh my fiance
had when when we met and it's this
uh
she had found it when it was a puppy in
in a cardboard box
in front of a ross dress for last so his
his name is ross oh and he says sweetie
he's like he's like a lab lab mutt
basically oh wow great but but like
intricate to have inside your butthole
um yeah
uh what is your favorite fruit would you
say probably a
an apple
i don't know what's my favorite
blueberries probably blueberries what am
i talking about
like a nice ripe
wild blueberry well we've just been
eating a bunch of
apples the the crisp the crisp one i
forget the name of it but i always
forget it but i'm like god why why don't
i eat more apples i know there's one
dumbass
there's one that's in season in lay
anyway like it must be like three weeks
a year i forget the name of it but i
always think like
oh god kind of yeah the one i love is
like the big yellow and kind of pink one
it's it's
yeah it's so crisp it's like crunchy and
crisp yes yeah
well i wish i knew um and who would you
want to play you
in your biopic will in the untitled will
forte why do i want to play me
probably kristen wiig
oh yeah
does she do an impression
no or no
or would you say
right seth myers does one
except does one where he just kind of
talks like this
yeah andy does too i'm trying to think
of who
oh you know who would be really fun to
play me my mom i'd get my mom my mom's
she's i don't know if you ever met her
but she is a delight no
i just heard pete holmes on his thing
talking about uh
talking about her that she did a show at
largo that was sounded so fun um oh yeah
it sounded so funny no but you described
her and she sounds just really great
yeah i basically made i made her
i just said just do everything i write
for you just just uh
yeah say and she
did these things where she basically had
to tell off the audience but i was like
basically like
it was smelly kind of bit where i'm like
okay mom
mom uh
i basically had written all these things
where i was like so these are the things
that you told me to
remember
to to write down and then give to you
because you thought you'd forget them
and then it was like
um
you know
[ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
like she'd say to the audience i'm like
mom why would you do that that's crazy
and then you know okay here's the other
one that you want in just like i don't
know well there was more it was more
slightly more artful than that and not
much but
my favorite part of the story is that
she said i guess she like she was kind
of nervous she was about to go on stage
she said oh should i leave my purse
should i bring my purse
and you
you thought oh no she should definitely
leave her person you said oh no bring
your purse
yeah yeah i said i was she said should i
bring bring my purse and i i said
oh yeah for sure bring your purse and
then the moment she comes on stage i'm
like what the [ __ ] are you doing with
your purse out here are you crazy put
your [ __ ] purse back
she just she's so fun because she just
rolls with everything and just yeah she
she's really really funny uh who really
almost done who's your favorite simpsons
character god
this is tough i mean
homer is yeah always gonna be be
but i love ned flanders
i love ned i love i remember
when ned took his shirt off in that um
in the tennessee williams they're doing
street car
stella when he and he reveals that he's
ripped that was one of those moments
where i thought like god
these guys are just
so far ahead of the comedy curve they're
just that choice that's such an inspired
thing to make that guy ripped
yeah
um
dogs are you prefer dogs or cats gotta
say dogs i mean not even close but but i
have met some cats that that
that are pretty cool but but yeah it's
it's mainly it's you know all dogs are
pretty cool and for me it's like oh some
cats are cool but some are pieces of
[ __ ] you know yeah
we used to have uh this question the
simpsons one replaced it but i'm curious
about who your favorite muppets
character was when you were growing up
you i'm guessing you were a fan of the
muppets swedish chef i mean i like the
weird you know uh what is the gonzo is
gonzo the the little purple one with the
weird
yeah the yeah it might have been him or
i loved those dudes up in the balcony oh
statler and waldorf yeah yes
i love those guys could this go any
longer
huh
uh beetles or stones i think i know this
that is a tough one because yeah for
sure beetles but like
this the stones that's like saying hey
would you rather have
50 billion dollars or 49 and a half
billion dollars right
i guess i'll take the 50 but i mean like
but it'd be great and like in like you
know and sometimes
sometimes i prefer the 49 and a half
billion like yeah i just
right
i mean that stretch of freaking
baker's banquet uh sticky fingers uh
yeah
goat head soup was it is that the one or
is it no no let it bleed let it bleed
whatever that forward stretch
yeah album stretch
it's just
unbelievable but i mean yeah beetles or
i don't know
would you ask me next year and i might
go the other way but but yeah you know
do you do any of those guys the beatles
or the stones do you i i heard your joni
mitchell
is really great um you do a great
joining me
oh do i do impersonations of any of the
beatles yeah
what are you doing
what do you think
what do you think this is uh you know i
don't even know
do you all dc that's no that's
definitely this is definitely the
beatles i don't want to introduce
another little
here's another one hello oh you drew all
of them
and of course i'm here too
i'm here too cheerio
and then it's little old me well that's
fine
but this is the fourth beatle oh
yes
well
this one was just the the third beatle
doing a second voice he was
trying out a voice oh
by the way that's right
you did that uh
what was the impression that's such a
brilliant uh idea to do an impression of
somebody who has a cold oh you're martin
sheen oh martin
impression that was my that was the
there's no d it was pretty audition for
snl is the snl one i did the yeah
i just was you know
i am martin keane
i don't do a personal impersonation so i
was like but this is a great dude i
gotta figure out i had never
i did i mean the impersonations i would
do with the groundlings were all like
you know
weren't impersonations it was just like
uh
what's uh what the hell's the dude uh
gordon lightfoot i was
and i had never once looked at uh
looked up gordon lightfoot doing an
interview or anything i just like would
talk to however i wanted
jordan like oh how how do i think gordon
lightfoot would would talk based on
hearing him saying sundown
so it's like
it was so weird to try to like oh to do
an impersonation where you have to try
to sound like somebody
yeah but you got out of it with the with
the martin sheen one by just saying uh
yeah
what was that oh that's right i said oh
our martian
i've i've had a cold lately so if uh you
know if i sound like myself grape but if
i if i don't it's cause that cold
that's so dumb i'm sure i had it worked
out a little bit more but not much it's
probably probably even better than what
i had taken
two weeks to work up
um
uh seinfeld or friends if if they were
on
which one do you watch seinfeld friends
and cheers
yeah
cheers is probably
my favorite all time oh yeah uh
i mean
favorite of like the old
yeah sitcoms cheers small wonder
um don't wonder
golden girls
oh really you know what i never really
knew the golden girls
it wasn't that i watched and didn't like
i just there are certain ones that i
just didn't see in the uh cheers that
was like super funny and loving the
characters i i didn't feel yeah it was
just something about cheers it was
it was such a magical show and when you
were falling in love with comedy
probably and you were that age where you
were it was the show
yeah
um uh ketchup or mustard
ketchup
yep uh and well what's what's the one
adjective you'd want people to use to
describe you after you've
left the earth
um
giving
giving would be the one that i think
would be
which i don't know that
you know that's the thing is like oh
that's the challenge to myself is like i
don't think people would say that right
now
um
well that would be that would be the
goal is to like oh well why don't you
[ __ ]
do more to make it be the case that that
is what people say about you
um you know i i don't know i go through
stretches where i'm i am a very giving
person and then i'll just kind of tune
the world out so
well you've been um you know you've
given me way too much of your time i i
really i can't you know how many texts i
have added to the list now
[Laughter]
i can imagine um
well i hope you get to all of them uh
you are you should never second guess
your your your goodness and your
generosity i you've always been such a
kind presence when whenever i've been
around yeah i love being around you and
this was so fun well let's hang out once
once uh let's do it safe again
don't do something karaoke keep in touch
yeah you too
thanks buddy thanks okay see you later
have a good night
so that happened so that yeah that he's
so that happened he's a little um
yeah he's a little crazy
yes that happened yeah that that yeah
but he's also very um there's a two his
elves he has a little bit of um
tom cavanaugh le yes yes oh god now i
want to hear it again listen he's got a
very unique voice there's nobody like
him i don't think he's really funny he
reminds me a little bit of fred
armistead in that theater
yeah never mind well no they're
different but they're both the kind of
people who
are so funny that even them saying the
most mundane
benign thing i noticed it when he said
when he said he likes apples at the end
and it made you laugh and he's like
they're the kind of people who can say i
like apples and that's funny you're
right you're right uh everything's funny
you're right potentially in a different
way um mcconaughey has a little bit of
that in a different way in a different
way they've reached this they have this
level of funny
that is that is so subtly funny and dry
at times that like it then yeah colors
everything else they say as being high
praise for mcconaughey i've noticed that
you've talked about him a lot
i can't get him on the show
since he's been a guest
he's starting to rival uh tom brady
mentions
i mean he's not
nearly there yet come on we also talked
about tom brady today that's true
um yeah will is there's something also
yeah like he gets very uh he's very
thoughtful he's a very good listener and
oh
and there's something kind of childlike
about him too which is another thing he
has in common with fred
yes i think there's a whimsy there's
like a a childlike sense of want like
it's wonderful it's sweet yeah it's
weird that right it's it's disarming
when he then does something
so dark cause he's also capable of
playing like the darkest those guys
those
like final sketches on center and live
characters you know um that he like that
guy who does
uh what's his name he talks
like this there's there's so they're
like borderline and fred's got these
characters too they're creepy it's like
maniacal yeah well it's like the story
he told about um his snl audition when
he did he had the gold the gold man
song
it goes from being like light sweet
innocent to so filthy
so quickly it's so funny i know
i i laughed out loud when he said
what tattoo he'd get he said
i he said i'd get my dogs inside my
butthole
and he said it so earnestly yeah he
commits to things yeah exactly so well
exactly that exactly
and that's an example of his like
sweetness yeah that he gets away with
endlessly into something super filthy
it's like a trojan horse comedian he
gets away he gets to like he sneaks in
through this guise of uh geniality and
like kind of innocence he is genial he's
genial and innocent sounding um and then
he he says something like that that's
like that's a perfect example of will
and his brilliance because that's a
funny line it's definitely a funny line
but it's it's extra funny when he
delivers it in that way right and it's
absurd but if you deliver it in a simple
matter-of-fact way
it it becomes real right it's the
opposite of being like uh i get a tattoo
in my butthole right you know like
really you can see that in a lot of like
bad comedy acting too i've noticed like
people like play the what sounds funny
instead of just like like you know we
watch seinfeld all the time there's no
better example of like
they're just committing to the to the
intentions of the scene they're
committing to the situation
i can't believe he's able to leave all
those texts unread
isn't that crazy it's unbelievable
hundreds for a year like four years i
know it has unread text i would lose my
mind
and part of it i like i was especially
surprised because he talks about
he i think he has ocd he thinks he is
ocd yeah
about that um like the oven stuff i have
that and having to fit it like once i
start a project like a puzzle or
something yeah but this sounds more
advanced just like the way he can't
leave
i mean you can you go check maybe but
like no i'm more than shag if i'm
leaving a property for like if i'm
leaving the lake house
sounds so
bougie if i'm leaving the lake
um
i fixate on the oven knobs and uh-huh uh
um and like finishing projects i have
like finishing a crossword plus i have
to do but so i related to on that in
that way but
i
couldn't understand how someone who was
this oc i know wouldn't check those
messages would not like fixate on what
those unread text messages said i know
i mean it sounded like there were people
that he really
liked that he intended because i have
occasionally all have like unread emails
from things that like i just i
don't want to get to but hearing him
read these texts that haven't been read
in four years on the show
felt
so therapeutic in a way and i enjoyed
listening to it so much him for the
first time reading these unread texts i
could have listened to that all day yeah
there's something so satisfying about
it's like they're not even my texts but
hearing him discover
four-year-old texts on the spot it was
so gratifying you know why because
there's an element of you can almost
hear the person's message read in their
voice and the voice has been shut for so
long it's like i want to tell you this
thing yeah it's like the genie is
leaving the body yeah and then it's just
like when he reads him it's like i just
wanted to say it was really fun hanging
out the other night
it's a relief it's a relief yeah it's a
relief
yeah i wonder why you know i wondered if
there was something that
had like he opened a text once and it
was like got bad news or something or if
there's something like triggering about
opening those maybe i if they pile up
long enough like it reminds me of
sometimes like when work to me piles up
i i get overwhelmed and shut down or
even like old
an email that you should have responded
to or oh yeah someone that is waiting
for your
if if long enough goes by you were right
you said it to him you said i feel like
um if a long enough time goes by then
you owe them you owe them an explanation
yeah and then the more time goes by you
owe them a bigger explanation and then
at a certain point it's like i'm just
going to avoid it because i don't
i'm not going to be able to explain it
well that's why voice text comes in so
much so handy you know because he's such
a good talker and he's smart and he's
like charlie yeah i i would just i
just i disagree with the voice text
really yeah because voice texts to me
are i think they come in handy when you
need to explain something but in terms
of staying in touch with people they
always feel like
a bit of a [ __ ] you
really yeah because it tells me
if i get a voice text from someone that
that i'm waiting to hear back from let's
say you get a return call from uh-huh
and i just get a voice text well that's
different that means
no wait they have access to their phone
they have time to call me
but they don't want to have a back and
forth they just want to say the thing
they want to say yeah yeah and they
don't want to hear back from me all
right so it feels a little bit like um
i know but a little bit insulting uh
yeah i guess if it depends if it's been
long enough um that you haven't
responded to somebody like that would be
kind of insulting his his lightning
round answers were great because he
would name like 30 answers for each
thing oh yeah and he'd get really loud
he'd get excited and then he like named
every snack that a person could eat when
he asked what his favorite snack was
yeah he's a real um i i
he's
he's into that kind of stuff you know
he's intellectual he's just a very
curious open i've always got i've always
really liked him
sorry for that chair noise uh his
beatles impressions were great they're
amazing yeah do you remember his beatles
impressions yeah they were like he was
like hello i'm a beatle and then there's
hello and the booty
yeah it was a little um
i agree with them about my favorite
simpsons character is also flanders and
oh yeah favorite emoji is also the kissy
emoji that's right yeah we have a lot of
crosstalk yes you do you do and some of
the like you mentioned the ocd stuff
yeah not to be proud of that but um you
don't want to be not what's the opposite
of proud ashamed yeah i'm not ashamed or
proud yeah good what is that when you're
just new when you just accept something
[Laughter]
should we read a letter sure here's a
letter from
pronounced like tyler okay cool without
the t
eiler huh how do you spell it it's
always hard for me when there's a
capital i and an l next to each other
yeah cause sometimes it could be two
l's like llama
llama yeah well then it would be a clear
l and it wouldn't be a person's name
yeah yeah
that's true eiler eiler that makes total
sense eiler tyler without the t that's
one of those things they must be so they
must that must just be wrote when they
say their name to anyone it's like our
friend kier yeah i was just thinking
that yeah it's like beer with a k yes
okay
subject the best answer to the
superpower question is
okay
that's the subject hi justin christian i
of course
eiler
i of course need to start off by saying
how much i love your show
we don't have to but it's really nice
eiler i think i really appreciate how
your relationship seems so much like me
and my younger sisters oh
she's one of my best friends and we're
only two and a half years apart so we
have many shared experiences thank you
for being you and sharing your life with
so many of us i almost feel like i know
you now that's so nice thanks eyler i
work for a community health organization
that you know that's hard for me to say
to your eyes
tyler come on you listen to the show you
know i can't say the word community
i work for a community health
organization in southern california and
my specific project involves youth
impacted by the juvenile justice system
wow
juvenile
not juvenile
as i'm sure you can imagine trauma is
basically the name of the game and i
spend the movie i bet and i spend the
better part of eight hours doing very
intense work god from the office no
working from home for us
listening to your podcast especially
your pre and post conversations together
brings me so much joy and allows me to
take a break from life for a bit i
listen to your shows and pieces
throughout the day
when i work out in the morning getting
ready for work when i take my walk
breaks that is so nice it's so nice
that we're like a part of somebody's day
so nice really flattering thanks tyler
listening to you too especially the
times where you check in or talk with
grandma jody gave me an idea to record
conversations with my dad and my sister
great for a bit of backstory my mom boy
my mom died when i was 14. i'm 29 as
email writing and i don't have any
recordings of her or anything to leave
future generations to remember her by
we all miss her terribly and memories
are copies of copies so what i can
recall of her is almost as clear as a
shitty photocopy
my dad's sister and i are
all extremely close and we've decided
we're going to get together
when it's safe to fly again as i live in
la and then in baltimore maryland to
record a few hours of interviews that's
great something i wish i had as a
recording of my mom's voice
this idea is really just because of your
podcast
that is so nice
sorry need a second hopefully this makes
sense and i didn't ramble too long
it makes perfect sense and it was really
beautiful thank you
i'm
that's me saying that back to the letter
i'm typing this on my phone as my work
ends for the day
if you all ever decide to interview fans
i think i'd actually suggest my dad
because he's got some interesting views
as an immigrant turned american citizen
that is a good idea actually
i know eiler eiler um
i wonder wishing you both all the best
with love eiler p.s i think i've
perfected the response to what would my
superpower be ah
the ability to make myself comfortable
instantly oh yeah
no more getting up in the middle of the
night now now to pee no more hangovers
etc oh i thought she meant more like
socially comfortable but i would take
that too i'm sure that's included yeah
yeah isn't it funny that that's where i
go right away instead of a physical
comfort
yeah i wonder what that says about you
also i don't think getting up to pee is
that uncomfortable i kind of enjoy the
break yeah unless i can't get back to
sleep there you go yeah and wait wait
until you turn 42 you have to get up
tonight i got up to pee this morning um
i'm gonna go back to sleep yeah full
disclosure and at 6 30 and i could not
fall back to sleep well i i almost
thought well why share that with people
but um
it's appropriate and especially now that
this is the interesting thing about a
show it's not appropriate it's
inappropriate it's appropriate for the
context exactly and also
uh that instinct i have might not be the
best because
eiler said it in her letter she feels
like she she does kind of know i mean
like that's the thing about a show like
this is we're not really doing it
i mean i'm not doing a shtick really i
don't think i'm not really performing i
don't think you are i i'm sure to a
certain
slightly maybe but like
so so to eiler's point like she does
kind of know us
um so maybe she would like to know and
now i feel like i know her a little bit
yeah exactly it's nice that's a good
superpower too oh that's great i think
um
it's a good example of like a non-active
superpower every other superpower is
like i don't want to be able to fly
incumbent on you to do stuff it would
just be like i want to sit around and be
comfortable oh man you know it's also
you know like in comfort and feel good
happy
and how great to like live to know that
you could immediately be happy comfort
because it's true what is more important
than being comfortable
right there's no more important thing
and i mean i guess i yeah because you
can't be anything else unless you're
comfortable could you say that
discomfort sometimes
it's certainly can be valuable that's
true yeah and um but for for
moments you know yeah not consistently
in my life not at six a.m when you're
right you want to go back to sleep
yeah
or i mean i'm thinking too that i love
doing the show i love talking to people
it would be really nice to be more
comfortable in a conversation you're
pretty comfortable in conversation
except when you talk to uh matthew akana
i was comfortable no i don't fetch that
wait a minute wait a minute all right uh
thank you eiler and
you know i'm so glad that we gave you
that idea
yeah we i think i record maybe too much
now i mean every time i see my
grandmother now because i think
you know you just i i know how valuable
those are gonna be and uh
and i'm sorry that you don't have any of
your mom that really
that really sucks but i'm so glad that
you and your
your siblings and your dad can get
together and that's the nice thing about
you know those moments probably is you
get to
revive her and and um because i i need
my memory's so bad like i need to be
sometimes people come on the show and
remind me of like
[ __ ] that happened well that's why i
also we have those voice memos at the
end of the episode yeah because you
record a lot i do often when people
don't know you're recording yeah my
friend james james duffy i'm sorry james
if you're listening he used to hate when
i did that um he still does
so i don't record him anymore but which
is totally understandable i wouldn't
like to be
occasionally like maggie started
recording us and like sometimes i feel
moment i like i i like having them and
i'm somebody who records it but but
there is a moment where i'm like oh [ __ ]
now i feel sorry but if it's someone you
trust doing exactly you know they're not
gonna you know
spread something around if you're not
comfortable right i would never do that
yeah and and and we should say too with
these voice memos we always run them by
if like our mother's in it because or
she says hilarious stuff but sometimes
there are things that like you know she
she
that we wouldn't mind having another but
like she she would be have trouble with
so anyway thank you thanks tyler um a
really wonderful letter and um really
touching yeah and um and thanks to our
uh our friend will forte oh and all if
you guys want to write in oh yeah to the
show we love getting your letters
uh our email address is justin life is
short at wondering.com and either if
you're not it's not justin no for for
clarity yeah just life is short
at wondery.com not just and wondering
spelled w-o-n-d-e-r-y
yeah
wonder if you were wondering how to
spell it and uh eiler you know when you
make a bad joke and you try to like
pivot quickly quickly i know how you do
that
oh one does that
uh anyway eiler uh if you do want to
write back and i'm curious about your
dad's immigrant experience and where
he's from where you guys are from and uh
i hope you do that record
each other and yeah i and i hope it
doesn't become annoying then your
friends like my friend james anyway uh
thank you for that and thank you all for
listening thanks to the great will
the great oh man is he
he i i was such a huge fan what a guy
what a brain what a heart yeah i thought
i knew you'd really like him really like
him okay and we'll talk to all of you
yes week so thanks to all of you yeah
will eiler
all the shorties thanks everyone
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
life for short is hosted by me justin
long and it's produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan monaco senior producers michelle
miche lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louis
and also one more hernan lopez for a
company that at some point some employee
named wandery
[Music]
but backgrounds must have been um
why well and wise why wise because
there's a caddy caddies are inherently
wise they give advice the whole jobs oh
that's true oh maybe it's that matt
damon's character got credit for being
good at golf but it was really matt
damon's character the caddy or the
golfer
or was bagger vance
i think i think will smith was bag of
vans does he come back from the dead or
something maybe it's because he couldn't
play he couldn't play what was that
movie about i'm guessing here's what i
guess backgrounds is about that he's the
he's the caddy and he can't play he's
better at golf than matt
plays he's black right
because it takes place in like the 1800s
i think
so he doesn't play an old version he
just plays uh an old fashion yeah yeah
he plays an old yes i got old-fashioned
yeah he's just from a different era oh
that's right
yeah now i i'm so curious what that's
about i wonder how it must be something
like that
it's about golf he plays a caddy what
else could it be that he gives him like
love advice
it's not like a rom-com
you